[Music]
I lost my parents
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
I love you monkey you lost both parents
in one day
I went back in time to save my parents
but instead
I completely broke the universe
if you went back and changed the past
this world must die
of the future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you fight that
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
I have to undo what I did
hey scars would have
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
foreign
no matter what we do
we're not going to be able to fix this
no
body dies
[Music]
you're strapped to your parachutes Hey
where's yours